oh my gosh I have an addiction in its
preseason football Sims I can't stop
watching oh my yeah I'm with you I
thought you were addicted to that ugly
shirt you're wearing I don't know what
the hell are you doing there what the
hell is that thing
just cuz it says Philadelphia does not
mean it's cool so it has illud Elf
bolded in the middle oh so the bleacher
report collaboration with the roots Oh
was it yeah Sam is 2 1 5 and the the
legendary roots okay
I'm damming the road stick culture
that's cool down with the roots that's
alright his energy just changed you
wanna box 2 1 5 is what areas very cuz
that's your area 2 1 5 it's still an
ugly shirt I don't care bleacher report
what the roots made it people were
looking at me on the train I didn't know
if they were liking it or judging but
now I know they were judging the soccer
jersey at first and then I saw the rest
of this so I was gonna have like someone
come in with a whistle and just like
interrupt us and be like up targeting
with the head but I thought I'd let us
breathe a little bit [ __ ] so we we got
to hang out with Sam dartle and Friday
for something that you guys are gonna
see cool and by the way Sam's an awesome
guy awesome New York Jets have a good
one in that kid but all we kept talking
about when we saw each other was a
Thursday night game and just the
reinforcements of this head tackling
rule yeah and you texted me and said can
I read what you wrote sure if you told
me the owners were on a mission to ruin
the NFL I would say I think you're right
every game is unbearable with penalties
it's making me not want to watch let's
start there because to me that's the
number one story in the NFL right now
it'll be the number one story and week
one and going forward we don't know how
it's gonna be called in week one
but as someone who watched every
preseason game as I did what was it like
for you as just a fan just a fan
annoying frustrating unfair to defensive
players for the most part that's that's
more the I mean I don't understand it's
it's become another handicap for
defensive players you're rewarding bad
football in a lot of cases that's what I
don't like about it either you know you
know there's just too many instances and
let alone slowing the game down and it
not being as fun to watch that's
really all there is to it that's what
drives me crazy I mean whether it was
it's this Thursday night started with
your Eagles Patriots game okay and there
was some just horrible calls in that
game I mean absolutely horrible I don't
know without even the head tackling just
bad calls in general yeah no but mainly
they had tackling bogeys on whether it
was the throw down the middle that Brady
threw 10 feet over cordarrelle Patterson
head and Malcolm Jenkins hit him on the
shoulder right and they call the penalty
on that Oh first down yep keep the drive
going first of all that's endangering
players they're supposed to be off the
field the event supposed to be up the
field now they're gonna be on there and
tired because the refs bailed them out
that's an interesting yeah that's sudden
it's annoying it's stupid let alone the
number of plays not only in that game or
let's just say they the best one of the
weekend was the AJ Bowie a1 oh my god I
mean he formed tackled it it should be
in a rule book how well he did he broke
down he put his face up he tilted his
head to the side so nobody would hit his
head and then the runner ducked his head
and put his head into his head and we
call it on the defense so that to me is
just unfair and they need to start
paying the refs more they really do
I think the ref should be paid 30
million a year they're the stars of the
show they're the most important people
the don't watch don't watch the game for
Odell Beckham jr. Aaron Rodgers
I want to tune into number 99 line judge
that's who I want to see I mean are you
[ __ ] kidding me get the hell out of
here I love football you know it and for
me to be that pained about it is it's
ridiculous and I really feel for
defensive players more than anything you
know I think we've texted the numbers
earlier today right is 26 against the
the defense and 5 against the offense so
31 in total it should almost be the
opposite there should be every time I
see a wide receiver getting hit I'm
seeing his head go down as well not
being called right really it should be
offsetting penalties yeah every single
time or how about we just don't call I
just don't like the fact that we're
gonna be sitting here for the next month
two months three months talking about
this and there's no solution the one
thing you've always complained about
with referees is that the game is too
fast for so many of them and there's
nothing more difficult to call in the
speed then
head being tilted also we've always
talked about how unreal a biome
it always looks intentional even though
it's not yes we've heard so many
defensive players come out and say I
heard Malcolm Jenkins after that game
talking about my neck is connected to my
head is connected to my shoulder it's
impossible to do it yeah I have a
propaganda possibility here yeah was the
NFL trying to get us so off of the
anthem debate that they created this
because they said we've already handled
concussions and head trauma we know how
to go to negotiate that just by going
we're trying to keep the game safer
because no one's talked about the anthem
right now yeah right right now
everyone's talking about this and and
the thing is from the NFL's perspective
if the referees can be the villain
they're the perfect villain there is no
sport or action and and I apologize to
Matt Camp who's a ref enthusiast people
are very okay with making the refs the
problem yeah right so I don't know I
mean it's a really good thought I never
thought the other thing that the NFL did
invest the players they're not seen
didn't ask the players for two things
this officer the anthem and tackling
with your head and those are the two
things that are causing issues right I
don't think they're that smart to come
up with that game plan I know but it
makes sense yeah we see more certain
political people that do that this day
and age I'll change the subject so I
guess that yeah so but but I'm just
annoyed and really whether the roughing
the it's being over reffed
and there were certain games where I
said oh okay they're letting them play
football this is enjoyable hmm I'm
watching play after play yeah this is
great and there was a few but then there
was other games like your game the the
eagle I would say your game is the
Eagles where I want to go yeah I mean
referee bill but vinovich or whatever is
I mean damn I just I don't want to watch
Tom Brady I wanted to watch him all game
that was awesome that's what I wanted to
do I'm gonna get you a rep I didn't want
to watch Nick Foles
be crappy or any of that either too I
wanted to watch the ref that's why I
tuned in that's why I'll be tuned in
next week I just thought it was the
worst a year to do this when you lose
forehead
like the most notable ones like our
favorite guys that's when you Institute
something where the refs are gonna have
more control they can vary the egregious
one my thing is this
this is what I'm hoping for yeah we've
watched all the preseason games right we
always hear week three of the preseason
that's when you're gonna get the real
action you're gonna get a full half of
the number ones and starters can the
refs call week three the way they're
gonna call it in the regular season I
hope so I don't want it to be this trust
me it'll be better in the regular season
thing because it's not why don't they
practice calling it how they're gonna do
it in week three I just like the teams
are gonna do it that's what I meant
yeah I think that's it I we would all
like to see that the letter of the law
has to be changed first of all the
wording of the rule I mean the wording
and the rule is so ridiculous and so
broad that you could call it on every
play at every position it doesn't matter
so the referees are gonna be able to
dictate the games that's annoying and
then the other thing to add on to that
like what you're saying is my my coach
friends I mean they're head coaches
they're all they don't even understand
the rule they don't even know what what
do you teach what do you teach our
players we don't get it there's because
one play it's that's fine the next play
that's not fine it's the same he tackled
him the same way both times yes well one
time it was against them I have seen I
went through every local newspaper in
the NFL last night yeah and every single
team had a gripe about a certain play
yeah like two teams that played each
other right one had a gripe on one plate
like every single team went we don't
know the rules yeah it's annoying and
it's a shame that it's become the big
topic but I don't know what to say
that's I'm actually scared for the first
time ever for football I am as a whole
yeah as a whole it's in trouble what's
in trouble and you've always felt like a
protector of the guy I do yeah I mean
I'm all for it but I mean we're getting
close to it looks like it's gonna be
two-hand touch or flag football here
soon and being strong and tough is not
gonna matter I think the hardest thing
about this discussion is that it's
always done with the player safety in
mind and we love the player safety yeah
why not before you start changing the
helmets and what we're doing let's get
rid of this [ __ ] field turf yeah
right because you know how many ACLs
were at the ACL epidemic 21:24 holy crap
for yeah with two preseason about player
safety though they are they're worried
yeah hey guys we're gonna we're gonna
penalize you fifteen yards if you don't
tackle correctly but I saw in the Giants
game guys running off the field cleat
get stuck in the turf torn ACL right but
we're Reggie Bush told us this - you're
gonna let these guys play on a surface
ventra do you know what I've never seen
a soccer player my life tears ACL
whenever Ronaldo and Messi are not even
allowed to play on that turf they're not
allowed to it's in their contract it's
against the law I mean the rules
whatever the law of soccer so the NFL
and the owners worried about the players
they can they can hurt athletes because
they don't want to pay for the upkeep of
grass yeah probably they're gonna
suddenly penalize players for changing
the way that they form tackle after
they've been playing that way for the
lifetime and the people that taught them
how to tackle we're do it's just well it
was just such hypocritical not it's such
hypocritical and it goes even to what I
heard you know Al River on talked a
little bit about how oh we got a you
know we have to have meetings and
there's a lot of bylaws in the NFL
[ __ ] come on and if I'll stop with
this NFL problem when you guys want to
change rules they change rules in four
seconds and they don't need one thing
from the players they just do it so
change the damn rule back it's stupid
and I had something else I was gonna say
but I can't remember people in there
yeah one of the things some news and
notes are we gonna clear up on I went
and it's been a while since I've checked
the Odell Beckham jr. contract yes pay
that man his money we had four hundred
and four people enter do you know how
many people are left
take a guess seven fifty-three
fifty-three Left 351 people have been
eliminated so that means in my mind that
seven out of eight people thought Odell
would have a contract pine yeah which is
interesting right there are people that
still think it's gonna happen next year
like that's what they signed up for but
fifty-three are left sat Accord in eight
twenty do you think he gets a deal
before the season now yes I know you
still think it's gonna have I do yeah I
do
III think they have to he's done
everything right
I'm a little annoyed about the overall
media coverage or the Odell Beckham jr.
I play I don't think it's positive
enough I mean he's being the most
stand-up guy in football he's risking
everything could be mr. team guy and so
the fans like him and Men nobody writes
anything about it you think in a way not
just being covered he should be
applauded for the offseason that he's
exactly right
I mean his offseason has been
spectacular work ethic I mean I know
there was the one video but that was
from two years ago right
I mean his off season has been
perfection long time right he's
performed in team drills right he's been
available for preseason exactly right
he's kept himself in great shape right
wednesdaya left go pr's yeah he's been
posting stuff for the fan exactly he's
done really everything he's needed to do
but he's still waiting and you think at
this point the media should be
celebrating more than I I think though
and I do I'm mad at the New York media
too because I think they should be
putting the pressure on the Giants I
think this if this was like Johnny white
quarterback and he'll I was in this
situation they blow you like can't play
this year without more money he can't do
it this is not right to do to our
franchise but it's you know I don't know
it's it's the crazy receiver we can't
pay him with me a crazy receiver the
other night yeah you were at Eva the
other day by the way we're gonna try
something that we're gonna be doing
during the season on today's pod which
is Simmons is gonna he went and watched
through some games and he always finds
notes and opinions that everyone is
seemingly taking the other side you
don't even know what people are saying
you just have your regular opinion right
so I dig through your notes we're gonna
get to that we you kind of sent me like
six or seven of the preseason game right
there was something interesting in all
of them alright good but if we're if
we're getting all of our gripes out what
happens to be what we're doing now my
number one was Thursday night I'm
watching Washington New York and I'm
watching the new the new core of Joe
tacit or and Jason Witten and booger
McFarland I wish them all well this Alex
Smith propaganda needs to stop yeah I
mean I'm watching booger MacFarlane
saying here's another thing that Alex
Smith can do that Kirk Cousins can't do
and it was they actually he said they
wanted out
like Smith of her Kirk Cousins if they
could have gotten Kirk Cousins on Alex
miss contract they would have done it do
you believe that I yes I also believe
there's nothing that Alex Smith can do
that Kirk Cousins can't do would agree
Alex is maybe if the answer may be he
gets five more yards in a run right yeah
but okay so you're a little disagreeing
with me no no I'm not disagreeing with
you third layer wise I'm with you but
there's these stories that I've been
noticing all offseason coming out of
Washington yeah the Redskins really
wanted Alex Smith right no they just
screwed up the Kirk Cousins thing and
wanted someone that doesn't have this
situation yeah and Kirk Cousins screwed
them too it was a double-edged sword and
they earned the right to say that he did
certainly there's I just think that it
felt like propaganda to me to go on
national TV and say that Alex Smith is
better than Kirk Cousins at quarterback
position yeah I think it's all right so
two things here disagree will be just no
no I don't I don't disagree with you I
mean I thought you were right the
propaganda was in full flat full mode
right first thing you got to do is
connect dots right bulgar McFarland
hoody pie for Jon Gruden Oh Jay Gruden's
brother right Oh who else did he play
for Bruce Allen the GM of the Redskins
Wow so they told him something and he
said exactly what they wanted him to say
hey bugger the sky's red tell everybody
it's red hey he's red it's red it's not
blue I mean that's what he did and
they're trying to sell their guy in the
organization now I will tell you this I
don't think I've ever even told you this
I don't think Kirk Cousins was
well-liked in that building more than
just Bruce Allen so I think there was a
more of an issue there than even the
public knows about interesting but to
say there's two yeah I think there was a
little bit of all through all phases of
the organization yeah what was he doing
studying I think that well I think that
I don't I think that they were
disappointment and lack of leadership
and the fact that he was holding the
organization you know speak to the fire
all the time for more money and there
was a few other things too that I know
that I can't discuss but either way yes
I don't think Alex Smith is as good as
Kirk Cousins certainly not I mean no I
think her cousin says you know he's a
more aggressive decision-maker
he's got a better arm he's better in the
pocket all together and the propaganda
just showed you too
I mean they made an excuse for Alex
Smith he throws the slant route into the
end zone I can't remember who broke it
up but he threw the ball behind the
receiver yeah and bulgar McFarland and
them got on the TV and said see the
receivers got to go get that ball
what it's a slant route nobody goes
backwards and then up to the line of
scrimmage to catch a slant route no it
was a bad throw but it just went into
the propaganda and they were gonna like
beat that to death all day long it's
gonna be very interesting watching the
Monday Night Football crew this year
yeah tessitura wants to take you to his
Italian deli in the back and get some
gabagool and some capicola and and then
you know Witten's gonna give you exactly
what the coaches see and I don't know
exactly what boogers boogers a really
well-informed guy I'll say that he loves
football he watches it all so you're
knocking it's not gonna be like this is
something I told you that he's brought
up of the line and you're like no one
watches above yeah I wouldn't like ever
watch Yeah right down the line of
scrimmage you know it that's it's tough
to see what's really going on when you
look at that angle
yeah the sim said this to me before if
you ever go to a football game it's
better to be 20 yards behind the play
right that's where you see the gaps what
they're trying to do right the play
callers are always there you know think
about your offensive head coach play
callers offensive coordinators defensive
coordinator usually a little bit behind
the play because you could see if you're
an offensive coordinator you can go all
the Mike linebackers about the Blitz and
the B gap if you're right down the line
of scrimmage you just go and he's
Blitzen what gap is he in upstairs
somebody's got to tell me so he could to
see it through the quarterbacks eyes a
little bit more that well then TV news
cameras are always 20 yards in front of
the line because you want the touchdown
coming toward you right exactly what
other guys a lot of Josh told me to stop
swearing he said watch my swearing no
must be listening over there Jon Gruden
some people were upset that you didn't
break down John Green yet okay but he
was with Peter King with football
morning in America and they did a little
write-up and he had a few things I
wanted to see if you remember this
working with it okay cool
did you ever throw no lace footballs
with Jon Gruden yeah so apparently with
Derek Carr he's given like a bag of a
dozen footballs that don't have laces
okay and there
Jeron Adam and he has to get him out
immediately okay because they found that
around 40% of Derek cars throws in
college you don't have time to get your
hands on the laces right a bad snap what
ever did you do that with young yeah we
did we didn't necessarily have balls
without laces but we just had to do
drills of throwing the ball you got to
get it where you get it in your hand and
throw like when you throw those quick
bubble screens your wide receivers get
it out
yeah you can't waste time going oh I got
to get the laces by the time you do that
this the guy's seven yards downfield and
you got a legal blockers and the
innovation of balls without laces at all
that's new that is new I don't I've
never I don't think I've never seen a
football I think is like an Australian
rules that's pretty cool
Gruden this is like such coach I'm just
crying so hard I can't even see my life
I'm trying to match my work ethic from
15 years ago that's number one you gotta
get everyone aboard I haven't seen my
wife in like three weeks she's got to be
on board it's such a coach thing to take
pride in not seeing your family yes it
especially for the old school coach you
know when's the last time you seen your
wife two weeks I'm at three yeah John
really grind you loser you haven't seen
her in twice two weeks you're not
working very hard I know it is a stupid
thing that goes on in the NFL like I've
told you before I mean there's certain
coaches you just sit there at the end of
the day they're just sitting there to go
I left at 10:30 last night yeah but you
didn't do anything from 9:00 to 10:30
you were just scared to leave because
the head coach was still in his office
or whatever it is but Gruden is a
grinder he lives it and the offense
listen I haven't I just watched a little
bit I haven't broke down the Raiders yet
because they don't play anybody they
haven't played any starters or any good
players yet so I feel a lot of people
wanted you to talk about like Maurice
Hurst they're gonna do some of the deed
like be a PJ Hill yes right looked very
good looks phenomenal yes and they both
look enormous well the thing is - I was
gonna ask you about with with crudeness
part of the reason they didn't play
anybody against the Rams Rams didn't
play anybody either they play week 1 of
the NFL season yeah so McVeigh and
gutten came out said I don't know why
you scheduled us we're not gonna show
anything to each other
but it's funny because like I watched
the Seahawks and Russell Wilson plays
the whole first half yeah Patriots Tom
Brady plays a hole for INF Rams and
Raiders I understood what they didn't
but why do some teams have
starters play the whole first half
sometimes even more and then other teams
they get like a drive like Matt Ryan
played two drives that's it I mean
there's no rhyme or reason it's really
just on the coach and him having a feel
for his players and what he wants I do
feel like a little bit more of the fat
as of late is to play some of your
starters in the second game and the
third game where they used to play a
whole half or even the third quarter it
doesn't go on as long as it used to I
feel like now they're like halfway
through the second quarter they get out
get the firt the the first teamers out
of there but no it's a total of feel
thing and I think that's all Gruden's
going by I look at Gruden with his
situation and go he just doesn't want to
put his babies out there until
everything's hitting on all cylinders
that would be my guest
right he doesn't want to mari and Jordie
and Derek Carr and everybody out there
unless he until he feels like okay they
got the offense they're ready to do some
damage and the preseason thing I think
is fascinating to like you talked about
with the Rams and the Raiders the the
teams themselves have the right to
reschedule two preseason games right so
it's not the league though really yeah
preseason games that's why it's usually
regional right right like when I was in
Tampa just about every time we played
Jacksonville we played the Dolphins we
played the Houston Texans and then we
played the Tennessee Titans all teams
that were then like an hour plane ride
for us that's usually how it goes the
owners usually scheduled a preseason
game so these owners just did a bad job
and not realizing they're to play each
other earlier this year or something
like that and they should have done that
so but but I do look at it like Derek
Carr Jared Goff I mean Carr was hurt
last year didn't play great golf I mean
he ended the year on a bad note and I
don't think he's at the point of his
career where I can just go uh he'll be
fine week one and he'll dice up defenses
yeah so that does concern me and I think
we saw the Rams in person right you and
I yeah we know they got ballers sure one
thing scares me about the Rams and I
know it's you to work together on this I
do think there's a tremendous drop off
between the first and second team it's
like what we always said about the
Seahawks exactly right is they don't
have the depth they have everyone knows
the Michael Bennett's and the cliff
haver oles and all these guys but behind
them there was nobody right and I think
when we were out there just kind of
looking at the Rams team yeah oh and
there is a sue right
oh yeah when they get Donald it'll be
good it's like you're gonna rely on
Ethan breast Brooks the whole year yeah
I know it's a linebackers were a lot
like where's the depth that right now
it's a little there's no like there is
and not and from that standpoint I think
where he has his team and he is kind of
their star driven and top-heavy yeah I
think he's he realizes that McVeigh I
would guess and he doesn't want to risk
any of them getting hurt all right so we
are gonna go through one more Gruden
thing yeah he was asked Peter asked
about the 100 million dollars yeah and
he goes I'm not making a hundred million
dollars just so you know well I never
thought Tom Cruise I never thought his
movies were any good but he's making
plenty of money there's a lot of things
I don't understand no disrespect to Tom
Cruise I'm sure he's a great actor you
know what you just go about your life as
hard as you can what one do you think
Tom Cruise is a good actor I I think Tom
Cruise gets a bad rap I'm not gonna sit
here and say deserves Oscars but people
make fun of Tom Cruise like none of his
movies are good sometimes I'm gonna go
no there's like over two dozen that are
good Tom Cruise is a little bit like
Odell Beckham yeah we're off the field
people think he's a little bit weird a
little bit out there and a little bit
crazy right but when he's on the field
or when he's on the screen Tom Cruise
was good Tom Cruise this has legendary
film legendary he's just with the
Scientology and the jump thing on the
couch I know Katie Holmes stuff yeah it
seems a little did he's five foot five
and he's always like I just like to
tumble buildings you're like all right
Tom like chill out bro do people say
that new Mission Impossible them's
really good that's what everyone keeps
saying buddy that's like they discovered
action movies for the first time but I
just don't know why Jon Gruden brought
it up but what does he mean he's not
getting 100 million you know every
[ __ ] cent of that I would think I
don't know if there's some clause in
there I don't really get that either
yeah I don't know he's crazy he's John
Gurdon he's got nine million thoughts
going through his head and they all came
out there in one paragraph I want to
give a special thank you to our
underscore 30 who sent me a picture of
during the Packers who they play the
second game Pittsburgh Steelers Steelers
came just a quick career stats of Aaron
Rodgers oh yes just quick update quick
Hayes touchdown interception ratio for
his career is 313 278 son sane it's
insane I mean you were what 12 to 18
clothes I mean no it's it's insane and I
know we've talked about this before but
we're talking about one of the greatest
gunslingers in the history of the sport
that also is the greatest protector of
the football in the history of the sport
that's that I just hope people
understand the and can quantify that
right there because that's like so rare
it's like the exam you know he nobody
shoots more fadeaway three-pointers in
this player but Manny makes he's the
greatest shooter of all time my god I
mean that's what he does I mean and
Brady's probably that's very Steph Curry
yes I mean it really is great he's
probably the greatest protector of the
football we've ever seen and here Aaron
Rodgers is like 40-something
interceptions less than him Wow that's
where it's just unbelievable I think so
I think one of the more annoying things
that I do other than interrupting which
I think I'm doing this morning great the
other thing though is I correct people
and so it's okay if I do it I'm gonna
ask in advance yeah you've been using
quantify a lot lately have I and I
haven't noticed thing give you a little
bit good not saying it's bad right not
even no but I don't want to use two
words too many times well I'm just
realizing that anytime that you're
discussing numbers you say I just hope
people can quantify it and I'm just I'm
just noticing I'm just saying a trend
okay all right that's fine coach me up
that's fine I'm not saying you just stop
playbook people can wrap their heads
around the idea those two things don't
mean the same thing yeah but they do
quantify and wrap your head around the
idea that we're watching a gunslinger
who takes the same thing well I'm
quantify means to like put in tonight I
still I'm getting this I should have
done it no I'm still getting the same
point across and quantified doesn't
always mean just numbers you're like
you're quantified number the part quant
I think is like part of class I get that
I get that you know you're a jerk
qualify right I don't know either I
don't want I'm sorry it's okay I don't
care trust me I'm not I'm not my day
does not go because based on my IQ level
[ __ ] you're gonna come up with text
me later and be like I was looking at
the definition of quantify all right so
let's go through I have a few of your
game notes I'm gonna try and get to all
the preseason games and just kind of get
our thoughts on everything that we're
seeing I think we don't get to film
why's here I'll get two for them
Wednesday our Thursday podcast so I'm
cracking away so first thing that let's
do is we haven't really talked about the
Giants too much so let's go g-man
let's go Giants Lions game I already
looked at your notes I'm gonna read the
parts that I think are are big go ahead
a few notes then want to talk about yeah
first note I liked you're really
impressed with Evan Engram you say he
really looks like he could be special
yes you also said on the on the the
giant side a little bad it's the second
week in a row they're just kind of in on
Alec Ogletree yes I was disappointed it
is disappointing to me okhla tree to me
looks like he has lost a step now he
could still be camp legs it can maybe he
has an injury that he's not quite
feeling himself I don't know that but
I'm just telling you through two
preseason games I've watched every play
he's played in and yeah I just
it's a something's on right something's
off what's not off though is where we're
gonna focus on okay you wrote that the
Giants first team defense what the [ __ ]
out of the Lions and you wrote the
Giants front seven is big Kareem Martin
is beasting yeah you wrote down all the
names on the Giants front seven and I'd
like to add something to that Lee's do
the Giants first team defense in two
preseason games on 28 snaps has given up
19 yards rushing I'm great I'm glad you
said that it makes me feel good cuz I
don't charge that but it just to my eye
it looks like they're whooping ass a lot
what are you seeing right now from the
Giants defense well specifically the
front yeah the front seven first off is
the size you know you're gonna this is
like a three-four hybrid type defense
right and when you have guys like Kareem
Martin Olivier Vernon on the edge of
that defense Kareem Martin's outside
linebacker who's I'm gonna read his
exact size here I mean he's six six to
72 okay that's called setting the end
that's that's a big man to be playing
and y'all even mentioning snacks in the
middle no and then the other edge is
Olivier Vernon who's built like a
chiseled Greek god yeah and he is on the
other side at six to 262 pounds as the
outside linebacker /dn then you get to
the middle part of the defense and you
talk about holy bacon ham
cheese sandwich I mean snacks Dalvin
Tomlinson he's been really impressed and
they're dropped pic BJ Hill from North
Carolina State this year they're
immovable they really they are immovable
they are all shade nose type of players
defensive line stoutness in the
preseason yes that's something that
you're confident translates to the
regular I am it still just grown men
holding their ground or pushing people
back what are you seeing different about
this Giants defensive line that you
didn't see last year because snacks was
there Tomlinson was there and Olivia
vertical yeah yeah I think it's just
more people at the line of scrimmage a
little bit more aggressive some of the
schemes the stunts the things you see up
the middle and with just three guys that
are basically pluggers like that
I mean Tomlinson snacks and Hill you
know Tomlinson and Hill were like 315
somewhere everyone that line and then
you got a snacks who's 340 they're just
not gonna lose any one-on-one matchup to
anybody so you're gonna have to
double-team them and then you
double-team them and you don't move them
there then it just causes absolute chaos
and then they're there linebackers there
middle linebackers to like oval tree yes
I haven't been impressed with them but
he ain't afraid to thump and then the
other guy be Jay Goodson the kid from
Clemson he's another one that he's not
afraid to throw his body around so
they're not gonna lose many physical
head-to-head matchups that's the one
that's especially going up against a
Lions team that kind of put all their
eggs in the new offensive line basket
yeah there Decker and Frank Rabb now and
Glasgow and Lang a little disappointing
but when you say this with the Giants T
lion yeah how does it impact you
forecasting them I mean it I just look
at the division first of all and the
three other teams they have to play in
that division are capable of dominating
people with their offensive line and I
think that's where they probably did it
first they probably thinking the Cowboys
and your Eagles going man we could get
steamrolled by them if we don't have the
right personnel and the Redskins
old-line which people are sleeping on is
up there as well and I just look at that
I go yeah there's not gonna be too many
games where any team is gonna physically
dominate the line of scrimmage and take
the ball out of their hands and run the
ball 37 minutes off the clock you know
what I mean that that is not gonna
happen
the concerns with the Giants are still
in the backend in my opinion relying on
Eli Apple all year even though I know he
was better he was better the the biggest
thing to me was the kid they put the
Reilly kid they put in number 35 okay
he's a third year kid at a Fresno State
Darian Thompson was underwhelming and
week one and I don't think he can play
free safety in the NFL because I don't
think he's fast enough that's my biggest
issue and that was his issue coming out
of college they put this Curtis Riley
there who's a cornerback but he's six
foot 190 it made their defense look
better he can cover more bat room in the
back end because they want to ultimately
play Landon Collins near the Box near
the line of scrimmage right all right
let's go to and that was good because I
think that's the Giants are one of those
teams this year that you go the record
last year I don't think indicates the
talent on that roster right and and very
undoubtable bounce-back team we are
going to make our official season
predictions I'm gonna say next Wednesday
okay so we're gonna get through week
three of the preseason give ourselves
Monday to kind of recap it next
Wednesday I want to do division winners
who goes to the Super Bowl who wins the
Super Bowl okay MVP Offensive Rookie of
the Year all that stuff that will be our
big show next Wednesday okay I went
through and picked all my division
winners and I threw it out I'm starting
again because once again I was like I
just reacted too heavy off one preseason
yeah yeah it's it's hard so let's now go
to Jets Washington this is a game we'll
start off with the Jets it's a game
what's up maybe you said Jets watching
this is a game this is a game this this
is a game that because it was a national
attention
I think people watched a little bit of
it but the big story lines were at Teddy
Bridgewater was great Sam Darnell was
whatever here are some of your notes
just from the Jets first off you wrote
this with three stars Jets hit gold with
Nate Shepard second week in a row that
he pops has a great looking body
yes he does I wrote down on mine right I
just wrote I guess I didn't transcribe
it on this but I wrote Nate Shepard
fills out a uniform yes he does he looks
the part as a D lineman right D lineman
great looking body he's the kid at a
Fort Hays State that I was a little
unsure of in my draft evaluation I'm not
gonna lie it was like a bouncer yes
exactly right and you know he was it's
small it's small football small college
football and he didn't dominate quite
the way I would expect somebody with his
measurables to dominate but man he's
been a pleasant surprise I mean he can
throw people around and like you said
he's just so well put together great
legs
I'm emotional but its enormous it is
enormous and some unreal arms that go
along with it he's not the only one you
wrote Jets have so many good-looking
front seven guys but they don't have any
[ __ ] the play up total baller yes right
so you're looking at them and you're
seeing a lot of good pieces yeah but
you're not seeing like not even Leonard
Williams Leonard Williams no it's not as
disruptive as I would like it I would
even say that last year no there's just
not a none of them get beat you're
exactly they don't lose matchups there's
a lot of stalemates all of that but
there's not that one guy like we've seen
in those next-level defenses who you
know whether it was the Texans in their
day or you know Malik Jackson and the
Broncos I know I'm bringing up special
defenses but just guys that can go and
shoot through a gap and create havoc and
then somebody else gets to bear the
fruits I mean they need Jordan Jenkins
to get like twelve saxes yeah and that's
just not his game no it's not I mean
again there are another team that there
nobody's gonna bully the Jets off the
field but I don't know what they're
gonna be able to in those games where
they're bullying their physical yeah can
they make a play to change the tide of
the football game that will be the big
the big question for them you are not
worried on the Jets defense though about
their safety
you wrote that Jamal Adams might be the
best in the box safety in the NFL are
you willing to put your name on it right
now I I am you know I'm and and I as you
were saying it I was like yeah I did
write that
I'm just looking through teams and I
just want to go real quick I mean
challenge me if you feel like there's
anybody there and Collins ever saying
that comes to mind exactly right Keon
O'Neill is the other guy maybe you put
Mike I said argue very strongly for
Canada and Eric forced fumble Drake yes
he is and there's very similar I mean
Ken O'Neal Florida SEC Jamal Adams
SEC LSU Oh Landon Collins SEC Alabama
shocker
okay but I don't necessarily view
Harrison Smith isn't in the box he's a
little bit of both
versus versatility I don't think either
the Jaguars safeties are at the level of
Jamal Adams I would agree with that as
well I don't really see anybody yeah I
don't think there's anybody in that
class of those three guys at least as
far as enormous joiners not an in the
box guy always kind of a hybrid guy
exactly right you know there's nobody
else yeah honey badgers a hybrid guy so
these are guys I'm talking about with
the Neal Jamal Adams Linden Collins who
become you could put them an outside
linebacker and you're gonna be a go
they're fine they can take a tight end
on oh the guards pulling they can set
the edge on the garden and you know pop
him either Specials Jamal he's so
special I think the thing that I'm
amazed by first of all his base and his
legs his just twitchiness is a lot like
camp Chancellor it reminds me of his
ability to be like almost like
spider-man with the legs real wide and
he can just hop around and change
direction and then as soon as he sees oh
I want to go straight ahead run there he
can fly I mean his two steps he's up to
full speed but it's an ability to
squeeze through gaps and get an arm on
the running back as he's going through
the tackling he might not make the
tackle but he slows him down enough to
where everybody jumps on any only gets a
yard yeah it's those kind of plays his
presence it's not [ __ ] the pie up but
it's oh damn Jamal is there I don't want
to go in that hole let me go somewhere
else he's the number one guy where I'm
watching the game and I have to rewind
it 10 seconds cuz I saw a blur yeah
exactly right know who it was it is uh
the other thing though for the Jets on
offense that I think is interesting I
wrote it down upon first watch and I
said I wrote I'm still worried about
Sam's arm strength
Sam Darnell yeah I'm just gonna put this
out there I like Sam Donnell a lot right
in fact I am gonna be a little bit
biased towards Sam Darnell I guess I'm
going to admit this to everybody now
because I'm rooting for Sam Darnell you
guys are besties we're talking he's a
good kid but you know I'm a mentor
that's more thing but I'm just gonna put
that out there so you can always I'm
never gonna badmouth the kid yeah hey
he's not boards just good but that needs
to be right we're gonna get to that too
but with with Sam darn old I did see
this and I'm trying to find exactly it
was they did all of the a chart or great
charts of all the quarterback
okay and Darnell's 21 throws all short
seventeen of them were six yards or less
and his deepest throw was 16 yards right
you wrote do the Jets a have a downfield
passing game and you thought that darn
olds quick game decisions and accuracy
was very good but you still haven't seen
the big time threat was it open and he
didn't take it or did they just not dial
it up yeah no they haven't dialed it up
really so that's the first thing I did
you see them dial it up with Ted well
they dialed it up a little bit Teddy
which is yes that makes me think like
and again they're trying to frame the
narrative and build this kid's
confidence and do the things that he
does really well and he man is he good
at reading a defense and getting it out
of his head he really is and he was it
he was impressive in the game because
there was Reid's real faith he really
does and his ability to get the ball out
with that motion real quick it's
phenomenal his feet don't always have to
be perfect and he can still sling it out
there I'm with you as far as I haven't
seen that Wow throw or consistent like
oh those are some impressive throws like
I've seen that of Alan Mayfield and
Rosen yeah I think with him Lamar
Jackson same thing Lamar's impressed me
with some of his throws but not nothing
down the field yet where I go there's
the guy I saw whipping it around against
Florida right Donald yeah this would
have been my question about him coming
in the draft when the pockets there and
there's a time to be made where big
throws are opened down the field can he
will he step on the pedal and force the
issue in there I do think he can do that
but I don't think he's ever gonna wow us
with like 101 mile-per-hour fastball I
don't know I don't I don't think that's
in his game I don't think it is but he
can still make it work the way but he's
also crafty enough crafty as hell where
I he's gonna do things that I don't
think I could ever predict I think so
it's like it's like kind of a trade off
with him yes exactly right what do you
do GM Chris sim yeah are you trading
teddy bridgewater are you starting teddy
bridgewater are you starting Josh McCown
I heard you say that's on Pro Football
Talk and I loved it yeah there's this
notion that if you start Josh McCown you
win right when did he become the best
quarterback in the NFL thank you it was
a very good point thank you so what do
you do yeah I just got I'm sick of
hearing that wall the you know the Jets
the brass the coaching staff
want to play the older guy because they
think you know yeah when did Josh McCown
become the guy that makes your team 13
and 3 I mean let's we threw the ball to
the Jaguars defense I mean there's been
a number of bonehead play yeah I would
almost say that I think Sam might
protect the ball more than Josh McCown I
think it's the way he played you're
right exactly right and this time you
dared to beat you're scared to be that
guy early us he's a little bit more
mobile and it could work but what would
you do I still would play Sam Donald and
still you're stuck he's my starter he's
done enough and I you know people are
talking about his interception you know
a lot likes it ball it was fourth and
three he had a forced the issue people
are forgetting the situations like the
Josh Allen play from two weeks ago it
was fourth and three there's nobody
there he ran away we gonna throw it away
turn the ball exactly right so he was
forcing the issue I have no problem with
the interception everything I've seen
those been very positive from him this
to this point and I do I think Teddy
Bridgewater looked good again in the
game he really did moved a little bit
more this time throws heading because I
don't think the future is Teddy and I
don't think it's gonna give them that
greater than advantage like oh okay so
they start Teddy all year they go eight
and eight and if they starts and Arnold
they go seven and nine and then Teddy's
not here next year and what was the
point to go seven and nine was saved
Arnold and then maybe the year after you
can go ten and six and make them playoff
because you're not worried about kind of
starting Sam off there against the tough
I like I know they have a tough early
schedule I might actually think the
beginning of the schedule there's
there's one part of their schedule I
know I've gone over it before that I
think it actually makes the most sense
to place him Donald Wright because you
start off Monday night at Detroit right
which is not the easiest way to go but I
think if you start him to start here why
not next two games yeah at home against
the Dolphins right at the Browns right
and did a choice when you start him I
okay what did Detroit become the Steel
Curtain all the sudden - no so I'd I'd
say go after him I think that's when you
start them I think that the Jets are in
a very similar situation that the Eagles
were in two years ago yes where maybe
they weren't ready to play Carson Wentz
right away but they started the year
with Britt Browns at Holmes at bears and
they went now's the time because you're
not putting them at Jacksonville week
for no but if he has three weeks before
that exactly could be a little bit
better I think that's the eye
think that's totally the way to go and
I'll say this because they play the
Patriots after their bye well I wouldn't
do that to anybody no well yeah and let
me just like this this common notion of
oh we have to protect our rookie
quarterback we don't want to ruin his
confidence earlier no I'd be the
opposite
I bet let's throw him out there and get
him going if this confidence gets ruined
by week five or six and he's ruined as a
player
we don't need he's not our quarterback
of the future so that he's gonna answer
the question notion and I know we're
gonna get to this a little bit later but
Tyrod Taylor Baker Mayfield I know
that's what you got there yeah is it a
bigger gap I think it's close I think
it's close I mean because I think Josh
Allen's better than Nathan Peterman
already well yes and so that's right I
think that there may be a sizable gap
between Sam Bradford and Josh Rosen for
right now right but Baker and Tyrod kind
of feels even two very very even and if
that's the case I know star baker III
err on that now the Browns are slightly
different just because of their team
they've gone one in 31 they have to go
okay are we willing to take thrown guys
in the fire before that's really hasn't
worked so it is a very unique situation
but if Baker Mayfield everything they're
telling me to be this great Pro great
head on his shoulders awesome leader
unfeasible whatever then damn he's
showing me enough right now that he's
capable of you know handling the
workload he's not gonna be intimidated
by the big lights and you know we know
what Tyrod Taylor is he's a good
quarterback he's towards the bottom of
the NFL as far as a starting quarterback
he's not gonna be top 20 he's somewhere
maybe 20 through 28 he's gonna take care
of the ball make a play from time to
time but the thing that always bothers
me about Tyrod Taylor and you know this
we've talked about this is it's the
place that had they were there to be had
during the game that he doesn't take
advantage of so people go away from the
game ago well he played pretty good he
was 18 for 25 for 220 yards and one
touchdown and no interceptions and I
want to go yeah but there was like six
completions that the top 15 quarterbacks
in football would have slung it in there
they might have gone for 60-yard bombs
and they would have won the game by 20
points but instead they had to play a
defensive struggle and lost 13 to 10 and
your issue with him too is his inability
sometimes I see over the line yeah I
think he's careful I think he's careful
and Baker Baker's not careful that way I
would have moved on to that game but I
do not want to avoid talking about the
Washington D line because both of you
came in the next day and we're like hole
both of you me and you
you wrote Doron Paine the 13th pick in
the draft that a lot of people are like
why didn't they take Derwin James you
wrote he has special ability and special
legs and you underlined them I wrote
down in mind Doron pain Jonathan Allen
Ryan Anderson Ryan Kerrigan Preston
Smith the Washington all of a sudden
they're only drafting Alabama yes right
Ryan Anderson Allen and pain are all
Alabama guys which is a good strategy
yes but their D line out of nowhere and
to hammer at home Gruden said we feel
really calm as Jay Gruden we feel really
confident that Doron Payne is going to
be a force in this division for a lot of
years linebacker Mason Foster added said
me and Zac Brown a run through gaps
trying it the running back but those
windows were closing he said it's crazy
to see on the field with these guys
there's nowhere for the running backs to
go Payne's taking on two dudes and
making the tackle
it's incredible to sit behind them and
look at the running back and be like
they got to come to us like so even the
coaching staff and the players are going
yeah and you said it last week you heard
from Washington that - Ron Payne was
special right but man does it flash on
the skate really does right I mean they
just it's again it's a little like you
were talking about with Jamal Adams you
just go man things look chaotic in the
middle of that run play there what the
hell wasn't they show the replay and you
go man Jonathan Allen tripped through
the gap ran over somebody Don Payne
through one guy in the grass
got in a gap made the tag I watch a lot
of guys and there's a lot of hand fight
yeah but with Don Payne it's like one
hand movement happens right here e
adjusts himself and then runs to the
quarterback like everyone else like
Tehran just goes it's vet he kind of
reminds me of fletcher [ __ ]
I hear you he's built a little bit
differently than Fletcher he's not that
big behemoth white but yes it's it's
dominant like that it's almost like a
yeah Kalia scam he's not that big either
it's almost uh D was Cohen short but
he's got more muscle than Kiwanis yeah
he's almost like a aaron donald Kawana
shirt combination writer and shirt
aaron short come on dawn or a Fletcher
Donald
Cox Donald Cox all big names that were
saying about Tehran Iran Payne looks
really special to me in that game and
like yeah I did have a little heads-up
about how special he was looking and
Jonathan Allen again we knew what kind
of study he was gonna be and not to you
know undersell him he was pretty damn
awesome in the game as well all right
Pat's Eagles you have some notes here
I heard someone on one of the morning
talk shows today talk about how Isaiah
Wynn injury was was crazy because look
who's starting at tackle it's Trent
Brown he got traded for like a fourth
round pick what's he and I want to go
are you watching the game I know cuz if
anybody goes and watch his own game pass
or if it's all NFL Network and you see
the great wall standing at left tackle
realize that holy crap the Patriots got
Trent Brown who was rated as the number
one PFF right tackle run blocker last
year and they moved in the left tackle
and I didn't see anybody get past him
all game and there's a lot of guys on
the Eagles that could take a chance at
him you wrote Trent Brown looks good was
a force in the running game Donte scar
Nekia has him right yes so that's the
reason it scared me when they made the
trade right is you're taking this guy
that's six foot eight 300 and like 80
pounds with good feet and you're giving
him two arguably the greatest offensive
line coach the NFL has ever seen right
and you're seeing something special yeah
I am I mean because it's a better
looking body it's like he trimmed some
of the fat off himself a little bit so
he's moving better but you know before
everybody evaluates and see how this
experiment goes out you know first thing
is how about you just trust some of the
people that have great knowledge and are
really great at their jobs I mean last
time I checked Carnegie is gonna go down
in the history is one of the greatest
whole line coaches ever and yeah and
Belichick he knows what he's looking for
in offensive linemen - he's been around
a lot of good ones Plus how many years
have they had non athletic guys and
still made right
because they saw the potential there and
they knew there was enough there for
them to work with and then scar Nekia
coaches in the mob number even quotes
from like Matt light that are like this
guy could be unbelieving could be
unbelievable he could be found there
left tackle for a long time I do yes
I think they're willing to ride ride at
home with him for a little while and as
long as they keep his weight under wraps
then it'll be no issue because he is
he's a special combination it's a little
bit like you know our guy that came out
of Oklahoma that's on the Ravens Orlando
Brown yeah I don't really care what his
510 5 is in his 40 last time I checked
the left tackle doesn't have to run that
can he stop von Miller from running him
over can he push von Miller or Khalil
Mack by the quarterback when they do get
the edge right those are those things
those guys can do because of their great
size and they have foot quickness and
and Niners fans like I don't think
should be that upset because he didn't
fit what Kyle wants exactly fits
perfectly with the Patriots do but Kyle
needs the McLin cheese and he needs the
guys that are smaller and I could like
Trevor bounce athletic but he's not
running all they're asking Trent Brown
to block down and collapse the left side
of the defensive line where Kyle was
asking them at the right tackle hey we
want you to run down the line of
scrimmage and then maybe work your way
up to the will linebacker and he was
barely capable of doing that other side
of Patriots Eagles games and game and
I'm a little upset yeah I wrote down
nick foles was awful like it was it was
a little overwhelming for me how bad he
looked yes
you wrote Nick Foles did not throw the
ball well be interesting to watch and
then this part really hit me hard
you wrote might be back to reality are
you telling you a big upper lip are you
telling me that the Vikings game in the
Superbowl may have been like a few good
games for foals but now he's back to
just the Dallas Cowboy Raiders games I
mean that's there's more evidence of
that in his career than to suggest the
others okay this is gonna be really
messed up yeah so Carson Wentz us back
at 11:11 Nick Foles is okay after the
injury right if that's the case I'm
actually rude
for it I hope that Nick Foles ends up
having and this is so bad
Nick I love you like thank you so much
for the Super Bowl you're incredible
but if Nick just happened to have the
two best games of his life in the NFC
Championship in the Super Bowl and then
never plays well again I'm gonna be
honest yeah that's even better
that's even better yeah the fact that
Nick Foles play the game of his life and
got me a ring right oh but it's a little
scary in the current situation because
we don't know how Carson's gonna be but
he looks good yes but you're a little
concerned about Nick yeah I mean and
again I'm not gonna sit there and over
judge the statistics and how that looked
it's not about that I'm not gonna saw a
single guy in the flash right he didn't
connect with anybody across the middle
no none of his deep balls look good and
he was like very uncomfortable in the
pot exactly right you said it and even
on the completions I didn't like the
quality of the football the way it
looked it was wobbling it was barely
spinning right all those things he was
throwing the ball and like his whole
head and body was moving forward like he
was a baseball pitcher quarterbacks
don't do that you sit on your back leg
and you rotate you don't see Aaron
Rodgers like throw a ball and his foot
is head goes with the ball like three
cantilever head yeah you can't do that
so ever it was not a good look and yeah
it is a little concerning to me and now
of course he's got he had a upper body
issue to begin with now his shoulders a
little sore yeah and I just think little
games like that should solidify and
eagles fans just go like he won a Super
Bowl it was awesome he played great in
the Super Bowl he played great in
Minnesota but the stars aligned
perfectly for him and they had to work
really hard to make him feel comfortable
in the month leading up to that game
let's not talk about let's not forget
about I know from Eagles coaches that
all they did before the Atlanta game was
how we gonna get Nick Ray they were
stressing out they were having seven
heart attacks a night why they were
doing it they came up with the perfect
game plan they just got by against the
Falcons let's not forget they didn't
score a damn point for a quarter and a
half against the Minnesota Vikings and
then it was a interception return kind
of changed the moment to the game the
next drive is a nice long drive run game
and a few nice passes and then the
wheels fell off in the Minnesota bike
so again I'm not trying away throws he
had some amazing throat surgery yes that
throat that touchdown to Cory Clement in
the in the Super Bowl was phenomenal I
mean all is he had a lot of great throws
and I just I find myself getting
defensive I know this is the Eagles fan
perspective of a reasonable Eagles fan
yeah I know that when the season starts
it's gonna turn into Carson Wentz versus
Nick Foles and the scary thing is is
when you have debates you want to
disparage one party as you build up the
other
I am a Carson Wentz guy yeah he's going
to be our guy for a decade right I am
NOT anti Nick folks no that's what's
going to happen in the media well Nick
can do this and Nick won the Super Bowl
Carson Wentz didn't win the Super Bowl
they wanted without him it's obvious
aren't that important like it's like
this nonsense but that's where it's
gonna go yeah but I also Nick whatever
he did for those two games yeah it was
amazing it was amazing nothing can ever
nobody can ever take that away from him
alright Steelers Packers
I'm gonna go obvious we both left going
Terrell Edmonds to all the people that
gave the Steelers badge RAF grades I've
taken him at the end of the first round
you're crazy
you wrote he pops he has great size
great presence his man-to-man skills are
phenomenal yes he kind of has a little
bit of that Jamaal Adams kam chancellor
on both feet type of thing too
yes he does and if you watch the film
you're gonna look at a few place and go
oh it looks like they beat him or
whatever no the scheme he did what he
was asked to do he made one negative
play to me the whole game and that was
there was a ball thrown out into the
left flat on a third down and he missed
the tackle and they ended up getting the
first down the Green Bay Packers from
the second team offense was in there
other than that he did exactly what he
was coached to do he's around the ball a
lot and yes he does pop and he can do
everything in that back end their
secondary you know it gets interesting
because Morgan Burnett's a nice pickup
for them Sean Davis isn't implying right
so big already sorry you think about
already burns and they got Hayden over
there no you know it's a little bit
better than yours Pass that's what's
intriguing about this to be the
linebackers the linebackers are gonna be
the big thing in the middle deep
question and I think that's where the D
line we might see Edmonds come into play
because he might have to be that guy
that gets down in the box here
a little cliffhanger on your there we go
alright let's make sure we don't slap
five later okay all right so there's two
guys though that this is a perfect
example of the public gets excited off a
play and Chris is here to dump a little
water on the parade just given facts
yeah did you see that touchdown catch by
James Washington oh my god
jumped over somebody one of our
producers Todd Pellegrino came and he
said man I see I see that James
Washington catch which was a great catch
you watch the film and you wrote I don't
give a [ __ ] what Washington stats were
it doesn't look good he can't get open
his route running his below-average big
play came on a double move against the
third team for the Packers was there at
any point where when the Steelers
drafted James Washington yes and you saw
this touchdown that he went oh no I
evaluated him wrong well I was know when
they Steelers drafted him because the
Steelers have such great history at
receiver that I did go oh like damn I
may have made a mistake he looks better
in person than he does in film or
whatever it may you watch the film yeah
I knew what I was right yeah I'm right
I'm right I know that it's it's I yeah
again not to say he can't add value to
that team there's no doubt about it
first of all he's not the third receiver
the the third receiver is Justin hunter
right when the starting offense was out
there yes right and and and really yeah
I just don't see it with James
Washington as far as the ability to
separate or crafty enough route running
to win that way he got open on one route
it was a bootleg when Dobbs got in there
he were gonna come back he caught it
along the lights the right sidelines
again it was like a second or third team
corner but yeah I don't see it and I'm
not in the stats again it's about the
look you know listen maybe if he proves
to me he can go up and Moss people on
the regular then I'll go damn it doesn't
matter if he gets open okay he's got a
special skill to go up and do this but
I'm not willing to give him that crown
against the third team defenders of the
Green Bay Packers you're gonna watch the
wash and hit Cam Sims did you see him I
did yes I mean I write he is a yes I
felt the same way cams
for Washington and finally the guy for
the LA Chargers Mike Williams yeah I
know I went that those were both elite
jumpers right hidden point fifty-fifty
guys yes that's a skill set it is a
skill set so if he can continue to prove
them that he can do that consistently
then I'm wrong and they really don't
have that on the roster no they job it's
not juju specialty not for a bigger guy
you're right it's not something he does
he has his feet on the ground
Antonio actually is crazy enough is
really awesome at it for being a guy
that's 510 it's amazing you're right
he's in crime he's incredible and the
other highlight is cornerback Josh
Jackson pick six oh man he looks like
he's gonna be special another guy that
you weren't that high on yeah and you
wrote Josh Jackson cannot be trusted in
man-to-man coverage
his short area quickness his transitions
are underlined not impressive second
team nickel his interception zone
defense great ball skills that's what he
is so there's another example of a
highlight gets on the internet yeah
people call Josh Jackson and you go no I
watch the film he has issues in
man-to-man he can't cover man-to-man
plain and simple I mean there's a number
of clips and I could show you them when
we get done where you just go damn you
know the quarterback just was looking
over there there'd have been a 25 yard
completion and 30 yard completion he's a
big zone corner with tremendous ball
skills but the problem is with guys like
that this day and age and the NFL you
have to play man-to-man you if you can't
play man-to-man you're not gonna go to
the Super Bowl you like the Denver
Broncos right you know the Atlanta
Falcons were able to do that and give
the Patriots trouble when the Super Bowl
you know you go through the long list of
lines the Jacksonville Jaguars yeah it's
the Seattle scheme but when they had a
matchup and play man-to-man against you
know New England or whoever it is they
can do that if you can't play man-to-man
with all these pick plays and all these
different things that go on in the NFL
now you're gonna be hamstrung
quarterbacks and offenses are too good
you know take you back to Super Bowl
xlix it's the Seattle defense it's one
of the best defenses in the history of
the sport yeah okay but you sit there
and play zone you you might dominate the
poor teams in the NFL but when you get
into that game against a good
quarterback
scheme it's just slow death it's slow
death how much of Patton's defenses man
it's gonna be it's gonna be a lot of men
with some creative zones just wrinkles
thrown in here and there that he's very
good at game planning and taking away a
guy in a crucial situation but I mean no
it became Revis Island because Patton
was there with Rex Ryan in the Jets and
that's what they do and Jair Alexander
though I mean he has a pulled groin he
has a pulled groin it was his first
action man he started at nickel yeah
he's he's lightning he really is and
Josh Jackson he could be a player I just
think jocks Jackson when it's all said
and done is gonna be better at safety I
really do I think that's his position I
don't think you're gonna be able to
trust him in man-to-man unless it's
maybe a big tight end or somebody like
that
one other note when Yuri watched what
did you think of James Connor upon the
second yeah no James Connors as I came
away going this guy's a different guy
he'd definitely get removed from cancer
he looks incredibly he's got a little
more explosion to him again I think he's
a really good number two I don't think
he's just starting running back in the
NFL
there were people commenting going ah
that's why they're comfortable with levy
on bail yeah maybe you know they got a
guy on their roster to Jaylin samuel
from NC state who I thought might have
been able to be filled that that levy on
bail role as well because he played
tight end I would watch for that yeah I
was because he was that kind of player
last year in college I got to study him
a little bit but hey Le'Veon Bell
special but I mean I do think that they
could get away do you think I'm Bell's
gonna come back fat no he's not gonna
come back fat he's gonna come back
totally in really good shape just not
NFL week one running back [ __ ] you think
he could do you think he's gonna play
this season all out or do you think he's
not gonna give it everything I think
he'll give it everything I don't think
guys like lovie on bail they don't know
how to go what if they run I'm like 400
times here you go you're not coming back
next year anyway we're pounding you then
I I don't think he's gonna say anything
I don't think he is I don't like you
kids I think once he gets in that locker
room and get some of that field he's a
gamer and he does a pretty good job of
watching out and getting out of way of
big blows he's usually the one to
deliver them when you don't expect it
cuz you think you're about to get dimed
and then all suddeniy lowers his
shoulder that's you over don't know your
head
don't know don't worry your head Browns
bills before we get to the quarterbacks
you wrote something you called your shot
okay yeah you wrote for the second week
in a row miles Garrett yeah is
unblockable right he is my pick for a
defensive MVP up lock it in I'm putting
it in right now and there's nothing
changing my mind he's the most
impressive rusher I've seen in football
so far in the first two weeks of
pre-season he's a specimen and his first
step in power or taking it back to hard
knocks last week when who was that was
that Sean Coleman or was who was it that
I got mad at him like when he like
pushed them back actually Greg Robb it
was Greg Robinson he pushed him back
like ten feet into the quarterback and
Greg Robinson got mad and he's like well
what I'm pastor ocean this lot we do
yeah but this is why you're a bus that
the number two pick Greg Robinson but
yeah
miles Garrett if he played the whole
game against the starters last week
against Nate Soldier and the Giants I
have no doubt that he would have had
three sacks in that game and lastly and
if he played the whole game last last
weekend against the Buffalo Bills he too
had three more sacks to Dion Dawkins
wasn't starting this is gonna stop him
and Nate Soldier wasn't gonna stop him
either
he was all over Eli Manning in the snaps
that he was in there he was very close a
few times other guys ended up getting
the sacks but he kind of caused the
disruption so defensive MVP that's my
guy right there I'm going with him what
do we think four sacks for the year man
I'm thinking he's like gonna be around
that I'm gonna go like 16 17 I think
he's have a huge year I really do I
think that D is pretty legit it's
creative and it's gonna be hard to
double them with some of the creative
stuff that Greg Williams does do mmm
yeah yeah you wrote down the other names
too you said Avery aagama Gobi Kendricks
you said that Browns tea is a lot of
studs you didn't write down Jamie
Collins or no I some of the other guys
they're good yes yes now there's a lot
of impressive looking guys on that
Browns front seven the Browns defense in
general Denzel Ward had another really
good game oh he was good yeah he was
good
Denzel Ward's all over his ability to
mirror and stay in the hip pocket of
wide receivers is phenomenal like I said
my thing with him will be just can he
break up the ball in big games that's
really what I look at once the regular
season starts
right Baker Tyrod yeah you wrote this
yeah what did I write the thing I like
about Baker compared to tie rod is Baker
is aggressive and looking for big plays
Tyrod always just placed not to make
mistakes yeah I worry that most of
Baker's completions are across the
middle yeah let's go to the first part
yeah so you think that Baker and Tyrod
are close but Baker's willing to take
the shots I do
Baker's just got a more aggressive
mindset you know he comes back drops
back to pass and goes alright where's my
20 yard completion I want to throw it oh
there's two guys there let me go to the
shorter one
where I think Tyrod Taylor goes he gets
to the top of his drop and he goes is
that 20 yard completion wide open cuz
that's the only time I'm gonna throw it
or I'm gonna check it down always not
wide wide open I'm checking it out has
some Alex Smith quality a little bit and
then not to say that's wrong you can win
games like that but I do think for the
overall greater potential of your
offense in your team you need a mindset
like a Baker Mayfield is Baker overly
aggressive no or properly properly
aggressive that's someone you know he's
overly aggressive Jameis yeah Jameis can
be overly aggressive Cam Newton can be
overly aggressive I'm missing some other
ones you know even Kirk Cousins can be
overly aggressive at times to me I'm
just trying to think if there's anybody
else up miss we were texting though
Baker's footwork his fluidity in the
pocket such a natural thrower his
ability to cut and his he has a good pop
on his ball definitely he can make every
throw yeah I think he has a strong run
the same darlin if we're gonna go that
way like yeah to me if you made me rank
the arms themselves of course Josh Allen
is one I would probably go Rosen - and
then Baker Mayfield not far behind it
three and then he had got more and then
he had Arnold it four and Lamar at five
like I've told you and my sceptical not
throws I haven't seen him let it go yet
that's what I need to see at Alomar uh
so who are you starting for the Browns
week one I know this is a it's a tie I
want to say go with Baker Mayfield
I just think it's gonna be for the
greater good of the organization they're
a but they're well I I mean it like I
was saying before it's a unique
circumstance when you're 1 and 31 and
there's no winning backbone or culture
there
can't quantify it I think it's a
qualified what would you do
uh I kind of want to pull up the pull up
their schedule really quick yeah if I
may um who do they open up against
Pittsburgh I feel like they open up
against Pittsburgh every year you're
right it does feel play all right so
they're their first game is against
Pittsburgh every year that's unreal
how much the Pittsburgh have to pay for
that so their first three games are home
against Pittsburgh at the Saints home
against the Jets and thereby is week 11
and they play at the bengals after the
bye man that's a long time to wait now
that's not a easy first three games
that's three at Raiders in week four mmm
home against the Ravens and week five
there's never gonna be an easy point
those first three games are tough
there's gonna be some creative defenses
there but again you know I just look at
it you got to look at the greater good
sometimes and I just think he's your guy
you have the belief in them let's go
let's get the show started you're gonna
deal with some bad plays he's a rookie
I mean Peyton Manning set the record for
interceptions as a rookie you know what
he did the next year they were the
number one seed in the AFC play you said
that Teddy's give you eight Nate
Darnell's gonna give you seven and nine
what's tie-rod gonna give you what's
Baker gonna yeah I mean it's I think
it's like somewhere along that range to
like where yeah Tyrod may give you eight
Nate the only reason is because we're in
that locker room with hard knocks I know
and we're seeing the leadership that
tie-rod is phenomenal I know I I
personally because I think that Sam darn
'old has the whisper behind him he has
Josh McCown that's there and I also
think that Sam's demeanor is different
than Baker yes Sam is a natural kind of
leader Baker I feel like I would be okay
with him watching Tyrod go through a bit
of season not a hole so yeah okay but go
through week preparations go through
kind of like what he sees maybe see some
of the failures see some of the success
just because like reading your notes and
watching them the
Brown's defense is gonna be there yeah
the offensive lines going to be good
yeah that I your I don't think there's a
fear of
Tyrod plays really well we don't need to
go to Baker oh yeah no but I feel like
if Teddy plays well some people might
say we don't need to go back to Sam
there's there's Anna Lord a teddy
there definitely is I don't get it but
there is yes I I know it's always been
like that with teddy and that's fine I
mean teddy he was a first-round pick
he's a first-time player playoffs
yes he's a because of a field goal
nothing he did I know that's exactly
right and there I think there's gonna be
suitors for Teddy that are gonna want to
bring him in as their legit backup here
at the end of he plays to get good again
in preseason game number three I got to
imagine there's a few teams that go we
need Teddy as a backup let's get to that
yeah so Jacksonville Minnesota after the
game
a Minnesota columnist wrote that bortles
was so bad that the Jaguars should trade
for Teddy so this is a that a guy that
just watched the game okay
a Florida times-union columnist so
someone that probably covers the Jaguar
says bortles wasn't that sharp but it's
not a huge surprise against the great
Vikings defense yeah I don't know why
this contingency of Jaguars like the
world is so willing to stand up for this
guy all the time and not go it needs to
be done here are Chris services text
messages during the Jaguars Vikings are
you okay with me reading he yeah guys
this is to me infantry bortles has
thrown four passes and three of them
should have been picked one was it's
hilarious
you actually wrote it's hilarious it's
so bad he completed a slant and every
other completion is a screen it's unreal
I have never seen a fifth-year
quarterback managed in the second
preseason game I want to root for
Jacksonville but also don't think they
deserve to win with bad decisions like
keeping him at quarter yeah yeah you
also went though to praise Nathaniel
Hackett how can you not but what's funny
is you you are calling the Jaguars
offense unstoppable
I know even with blackboard I know you
wrote the screen game is uncredible
incredible and neat hack it's basic
formula of play callings of of course
they're super talented offense makes
them tough to stop their old line is top
five yeah their wide receivers are
probably top 10 it's better than people
realize it's deep shots screen power
gain exactly right I don't know how you
stop it I know but they just got this
guy at the helm that's the one thing
that can hold them back yeah they should
have been up in that game 21 to 3 and
instead they were up 6 to 3 no I know
and he could throw an interception it
doesn't matter because the next play the
defense can is mumble and they get the
ball back and we go oh well we forgot
about that bad play that ruined the game
for us doesn't even matter because the
defense bails amount I know again I I'm
some [ __ ] when it comes to Blake
bortles but the truth hurts sometimes I
don't know what else to say I think the
first point is just kind of what I said
first of all the Jackson was the best
team in football their old line is legit
I mean it the old line is better than
people would even think because if they
had a passing game to be scared of more
people the running game would even
flourish even more right because so
people are forgetting that that people
go and play Jackson when they go we're
worried about that oh line in Leonard
fournette
that's what we're worried about and then
they go oh yeah oh man we got to watch
out marquise Lee Donte Moncrief Keenan
Cole all these guys can Mickens they
could all be man-to-man so that's what's
scary about them too but edy Westbrook
Dede Westbrook right I mean it's just
unbelievable the talent they have on
their football team yes and I've never
seen a preseason game number 2 where the
quarterback was managed I mean by that I
mean they weren't gonna let him make it
a disaster it's its second and 20 we're
gonna hand it off
oh it's third and 16 we're gonna call
screen they're never gonna let the only
time he passes on his own play-action
floater
exactly right which is what they're good
at because they scare you to death with
that run game you go oh gosh here comes
Leonard fournette the sledgehammer and
if you throw up 50/50 balls to the names
of the receivers you just mentioned they
catch it right or you saw like the deep
cross to the tight end I think that's
too hard I don't think so listen again
the truth hurts and when you make 18
million dollars
year at that position you know first of
all you shouldn't be listening to me
anyways you should just be focused on
your job but no that's just my true
feeling evaluation again it's not
personal it's just just I guess the big
question all this for me is Doug Marrone
and and Tom Coughlin yeah I know
accountability guys I know and they're
there like that game was really bad
I know and morones amazing I mean a
Marone and nate hackett they have
realized that they have to manage
bortles
and they find great little ways to
always just make sure it's in his
comfort zone like you said like I've
always told you I can predict a lot of
their plays because once I see the
formation I know the things they're
comfortable with him doing and they're
gonna find some sort of variation to do
that so again they're gonna be able to
win football games and they're a pain in
the butt the problem is if they get into
some games against teams that go okay
we're not gonna be physically
overwhelmed by your run game all the
time like the Giants yes and we have a
good feel for your scheme Pass wise is
he gonna be able to make some of those
plays to get them over the edge and that
first game of the year Giants is gonna
be amazed I mean that's gonna be a kill
fest they'll build it right other side
so when I first moved into my apartment
yeah a lot of people said Adam are you
concerned that you have a fifth floor
walk-up and in the beginning man that I
have excuses it's free exercise look at
my button my legs it's not that bad all
that stuff and what happens now that
I've lived there for almost two three
years is that it's become too much that
I've realized that it's prevented me
from doing so many things I get home
after a long day of work when I have to
go up those five flights I'm not going
back out I'm not meeting up with friends
I'm not going out for dinner I'm not
gonna get drinks I'm tired okay because
I've had to adjust my life right to the
fifth floor Walker right no doubt that's
the reason why portals where's number
five because he is the fifth floor
quarterback the fifth or walk ups of
quarterbacks it's not is it a good
apartment yes it's a great apartment but
it's if it was on the first floor or if
it was like an easy to get to her I had
an elevator but I have to make all these
reasonings as to why it's okay I know
and that's what I see with bortles yeah
they're defending something that they
know is
wrong and I just don't understand
because it's the number one thing that I
thought the military was great at the
military doesn't allow you to lie the
military the truth is there we will not
and yet they still do it and I agree
with you it's it's partially why I'm
gonna give a little preview and think
about leaving the Jaguars out of the
playoffs this year yeah I hear you cuz
they because it can get ugly with them
you know yeah they can't score
touchdowns all the time on defense right
you know like coleus Campbell forced the
fumble and it got recovered there and
it's an amazing and every other team
should go we get the ball in the 35 the
Jaguars are the only team they're like
man I wish you could return that to the
20 yeah I really wish yeah like verily
we had that expectation with them too
cuz they did it last year I know but I
just know that every this is a fantasy
thing but every like number one like
incredible defense and fantasy wasn't
even like in the top ten the next year
it just doesn't happen it's it's just
too hard to bet all right it's
frustrating I know it's frustrating it
really is because they could be dynasty
material I mean that's what they could
be I mean like we talked about I know we
will it take for them to finally say we
need to change that we need to trade for
Teddy bridge if they don't make the
playoffs this year so we got to go
through the whole guy thing so there
won't be like five games in a row where
he throws pick sixes
I don't think so they've they've
whatever backing offense what if Jilin
Ramsay like they just start getting
frustrated they start getting vocal
about it yeah I don't know there's a you
know what are they gonna do go to Cody
Kessler I don't know I just don't think
they're gonna make that trade during the
significant time of the year because
they don't even want to go down that
road they don't want to start that
conversation of course because as soon
as they trade yeah quarterback
controversy exactly right so it's so but
you think maybe next year I think if
they didn't make the playoffs this year
that they would cut the ties I think
they would cut them religion Emily I
think they take the cap hit everything
because they're the best team in the NFL
they have the 52 best players in the
sport I think you and I were talking the
other day I mean we went through their
defense once again we could sit there we
were in I think in the bar room they on
Friday right we were talking about if we
go through their defense at all three
levels you can make a case that they
have the best e line in football the
best linebackers in football
and they definitely had the best
secondary in football so and I would
really say defensive line they really
have the best defensive line - I don't
think if it's it's arguable really no so
that's when you're having adding guys
like Dave and Brian exactly were just
like Roman out there I was like a third
stringer yeah that's like destroying
people I know and I gotta watch that
game on film I just watched that one on
TV
but yeah I mean it just hey you should
be concerned in Essos defense like
really good they did really look good
and you should be concerned when guys
like TJ Yeldon are leading your team and
receiving because the screen games and
there with your starters and then you're
starting offense couldn't go down and
score when they still took the backups
out in Minnesota yeah that would be
concerning all right one last game and
then obviously like likesome said we're
gonna get to some of these other games
on Wednesday - yeah
Chiefs Falcons first thing you wrote is
mahomes so many impressive throws had a
touchdown called back for illegal
formation that dropped interception the
end zone is what you worried about but
you were very impressed yeah I came away
with the highlight the one - Tyree kill
right okay yeah one the statistics on
that are pretty damn and they are right
aren't they
sixty eight point six yards in the air
the longest completed air distance in
the last two years I was with sand
Arnold that highlight happened I showed
it to him and I said that he goes that's
insane yeah he goes I couldn't do that
ever I go it's wild but then he had a
few clutch third down throws - Travis
Kelce on some outs and stuff that were
great yes he had a throw where there was
a pass rusher and a beautiful touch to
Kareem hunt who had a one-handed catch
right it was a complete game exactly it
really was it wasn't just rifles and
bombs it wasn't just the one buck yes
right no I mean I'm with you a the
overall look again you know is it gonna
be perfect with him all year long no
it's not gonna be he's gonna have some
like Brett Favre type interceptions
where you're gonna go man why did you
try to throw that ball across your body
at the three yard line and get that
intercepted I mean that's what's going
to happen but he's also gonna have to
times a game we're gonna go damn he just
threw that ball over the whole damn
defense over there and Tyree kill caught
it 75 yards down the field I mean
between mahomes and Josh down we're
gonna see records broken and I think
but these balls completed in the air but
these two because they're just they're
they're they have arm
I just don't think josh has the guy no
maybe not exactly longer down the road
but yes this this offense is gonna be
very exciting for Kansas City yeah
Kansas City just I don't think they're
gonna be as good a football team overall
Kansas City is an amazing team to get
fantasy players from yes I because
there's the defense who's gonna let up a
lot of points this year you wrote Chris
Jones is the only baller really in the
front 70s I was looking at some of the
rookies they got they were okay yeah you
like the 57 the linebacker though lied
you like I do okay yeah it's just it's
just big physical guy it's like SEC he
was impressive looking yes I didn't find
his movement to be that I didn't do
anything special but they're a great
team because they're gonna have to keep
putting up points I think so
I feel the same way about the cheese I
do about the Niners great fantasy teams
I trust both coordinators I trust both
offensive lines
I like the weapons and the defense I
don't have faith in yeah I know it's
scary I mean there's no Anthony Hitchens
no Eric Berry in the game right it's
still it's the overall look is I just
don't know if there's a enough Lisa
Landis can trick yeah I know I don't
know if that's gonna really matter I
know but you liked Calvin Ridley very
smooth good route runner yeah not that
explosive I thought even his double move
catch exactly I went that was a smooth
move it was but he didn't get as much
away yeah I think that's really what it
is I think he's gonna be really
well-rounded he's gonna be a great
compliment to to Jones and sinew he can
do everything but yes at no point do I
think Calvin redly he's gonna be this
superstar Julio Jones AJ Green Mike
Evans Odell Beckham jr. we're gonna go
oh he might go 70 in any play no he's
gonna be more of a let's say Roddy White
type of guy lots of catches readable and
do do some great things along the way
just to other like game notes before we
keep going one Cardinal Saints I thought
Josh Rosen really did look phenomenal
but I wrote down that I noticed your
concern of having effective mobility and
right
all the other guys in this draft can
elude a pass rush yep darn old Mayfield
an Alan they're like incredible like
Alan's touchdown like jump out of the
way was great
Baker's done it so many times this point
it's like not even a shock yeah but
rosin it's why I was talking to Conor
Conor Rogers from stick to football yeah
and I said he's got this Jamis quality
about him I think Josh Rosen has a
Jameis Winston quality about him where
he'll get in trouble and he just kind of
throws the ball up right and it's really
scary like he had three or four plays in
each preseason game yeah where he's got
someone in his face in his leg he's like
it's either like an intentional
grounding or he's just throwing it in
people's directions that really scares
me and that was the first time I saw
what you were saying which is he doesn't
have like when I was talking to Darnell
I said you're not the fastest guy I said
but you're quick steps are amazing yeah
like he got out of Ryan Kerrigan swaying
a step right Rosen doesn't have no it's
a little it's a little it's a step slow
from what we see in this day and when
he's throwing it down the seam it is
pure it's beautiful it is it looks like
Payton almost yeah I hear you you're
right it's it's a little bit like that
as far as the motion I think he's really
he's built like a Clydesdale yeah I mean
he listened he looks phenomenal out
there his throwing is it's you know it's
pure every time it leaves his hand it's
always a perfect spiral there's more top
on it than people give him credit for
even the touchdown throughout throat a
Christian Kirk I haven't watched this
game of them in highlights yet yeah
beautiful kitchen Kirk sounds like you
know he might be a guy I was wrong about
coming out in the draft because I was
not as high on him but yeah I'm pretty
impressed with what I've seen from
Rosen's I mean he was a special thrower
with some of the offensive line issues
exactly scheming in this game right it's
funny I was watching christiane Kirk and
I went man I see a lot of sterling
Shepherd in his game and then I see an
article in The Arizona Republic that
says that he's is Cristian Kirk the next
Odell Beckham and I went wait what and I
was like wrong receiver so I clicked on
it and it it was our guy Justin Pugh he
said he kind of reminds me of a number
nother number 13 I used to play with
right so I'm just gonna help you I
texted pew yes and I sent him the link
and I said are you out here comparing
him to
- O'Dell he goes man they were hounding
me for some compliments and I just kind
of went with it I was like you can't
compare Kirk just give them sterling
Shepherd kinda reminds me of Sterling
Shepherd I can see that when you said it
I was like yeah they have a similar body
type run they both have great control
yeah yeah the only other thing was a
note from the Raiders Rams game Raiders
fans outnumbered the Rams fans three to
one maybe four or five to one in the
crowd of 55,000 so here they've taken
all the teams to LA except the one team
from LA and of the 55,000 fans in
attendance for no starters on either
team about 35 to 40,000 them were
Raiders fan though great as they were
like there was an article that man the
Rams looked really like the Rams fans
were uncomfortable there were so many
Raiders fans that is hilarious
I didn't watch much of that game I it
was on TV and once I was like damn no
nobody's playing I kind of went on with
it I am I'll give it a quick look before
we do our Wednesday taping of the
podcast cuz I do want to see a few young
guys but yeah that's a weird it's a
weird city I mean it's a weird say it's
a Raider city now they're going to Vegas
it does last you're right all right so
three fans stuff and obviously again if
your team's where I mentioned we're
gonna get to it'll get to it one two a
deep dive first one is the Wiley's world
the hypothetical of Khalil Mack joining
the Packers makes me think about the
impact that Reggie White had on the pack
in the 90s
what would a trade do to the Packers
outlook yeah if the Packers got Khalil
Mack yeah
what is your mindset change with them in
the season it does make them that much
more dangerous the Packers are another
team I look at and go you know who would
the difference makers on their defense
really like Clay Matthews is he's solid
the names that always come to my mind
right Kenny Clark and Muhammad Wilkerson
right and we like Daniels right those
three guys they got to do some butt
whuppin because the middle linebacker
you're Oren berkshires rookie who's
athletic but yeah I mean we're not gonna
sit here and say Martinez exactly right
you know they're I don't think any of
their safeties are physical and a lot of
their corners kind of scare me yeah it's
a there's a lot of questions there
certainly I mean no
Khaleel Mac would bring them into the
category of okay this is not just gonna
be have to be aaron rodgers doing it all
by himself
now they got another guy who can make a
game-changing play you know four or five
times during the year the packers are
interesting to me in a trade because of
how they attack the draft this year
right
moving down and then moving back up and
in essence coming away with Jair
Alexander and a first-round pick right
who they maybe have taken their this new
GM gutten Kuzon Coast which I'm always
afraid I'm gonna say something
inappropriate
Ryan BG he looks like a guy that's
willing to make moves after a decade of
Thompson who said we're gonna draft two
we draft right my only thing with that
go ahead I didn't mean there say they
have two first-round picks next year I
know they could do it would you give up
two first two of those first two round
picks next year for Khalil Mack not
would you make the deal if you're the
Raiders would you do that if you were
the Packers yeah two first-round picks
for Khalil Mack two first-round picks
next year for Khalil Mack would you do
it alright so this isn't my mind went
here first cuz the Packers got the picks
they do and the my first thing is how
can you pay Aaron Rodgers and Khalil
Mack that was my first mine where it
went right where I was just like damn
what are we gonna do we're gonna pay
them 70 million 70 million and then the
other the other 51 guys get the 70
million left over I mean that's where I
are you know that's where I think it's
it's it might not be doable from that
standpoint ah man to first rounders for
Khalil Mack Oh in the same draft I know
I'd probably do it you would I probably
would those first rounders came from
where the the Saints and it was and of
course it's gonna be their own witch so
you're gonna have two first-round picks
at the end of the first round as which I
would guess somewhere between 22 and 32
if you made me forecast the season I
think the Packers will get in the
playoffs in some capacity and I think
the Saints to hell to how you do yeah I
do and so yes I would probably do it if
that was the case everybody was no issue
Raiders would you do it no okay I
wouldn't do it if I'm the Raiders
I wouldn't the Raiders they got nothing
they can they can hang their lunch pail
on right now and that's defense what
what what else is there to it these
defensive line I know the Jets were
involved and Khalil Matt conversations
yes we do not we do know that but that
didn't happen
varsity ginger 55y ginger
why isn't Zach Thomas in the Hall of
Fame hmm seven Pro Bowls five all pros
around 1100 tackles always remembered
him right up there with Urlacher and
Lewis as the best middle linebackers in
the game I'm not gonna put up in ray
Lewis's category but I do think he is as
good as Brian Urlacher I do I think he's
a Hall of Fame middle linebacker I
really do
Zach Thomas other than Ray Lewis I think
was also it was the most intimidating
linebacker I played against just because
his ability to call plays out was
unbelievable I mean he really he was the
best at calling plays out that I ever
went against let alone him being like a
rocket he is a muscle and he's like 511
six foot and could pack a punch and
really never came off the field he's a
Hall of Fame type player he really is I
mean it's it's to me if you really asked
me who's better between him and hurt him
in her locker it's very close I'm
realizing that there's this thing that
happens with NFL players towards the end
or at the end of their career they're
constantly called a future hall-of-famer
yeah and then when they retire and then
they have to wait five years they're
forgotten Zach Thomas was one of those
guys yeah you're right where the rest of
it the second half of his career Gus is
a future hall-of-famer
yeah Allen Faneca was like that I would
even say like Richardson the full-back
was like sure where people would be like
oh I mean he's a future hall-of-famer
because when you're in year 12 13 14
you're still doing it that's happening
Larry Fitzgerald right now yeah future
Hall of Famer Larry Fitzgerald no doubt
but then sometimes you get forgotten and
that's what seems like it's happening to
Zac Todd it just seemed like it I
haven't even thought about his name
Brian Urlacher did not deserve to be a
first-ballot hall-of-famer okay he
probably deserve to be on the Hall of
Fame maybe the third year something like
that Zach Thomas I think that should be
similar to him he should be wait three
four years and then he should be in the
mix as well you know those Dolphins
teams they had some good defenses he had
Jason Taylor on there yeah and I would
argue that a lot of times you were
more worried if not you know every bit
as worried about Zack Thomas as you were
Jason Taylor and do not forget about Sam
Madison and Patrick certain day I'd bone
that was amazing yeah that's I know nick
saban their head coach there for a
little while I got to play against that
group man but yeah there's a commoner
man was pretty amazing I always say this
about Brian Urlacher like where I get
into this and people might hate on me
because again her lot
Urlacher is a Hall of Famer but there
was a time and period in like 2004 5 6
where Urlacher was really good but I'm
just telling you I don't think he was
the best linebacker around the Bears
Brett Lance Briggs was the guy that I
know when we played in Tampa listen we
were worried about her locker but we
were more worried about Lance Briggs he
was the guy we were like man he can ruin
the game right yeah he was the guy he
was funny how that happens happen
alright guys we went deep deep deep deep
into the film study there so I hope you
guys like that we're gonna be back on
Wednesday Wednesday night Thursday
Yeti's kuryak and then tonight Spanish
are mad at 1588 that is career and then
Ravens bears tonight
Ravens Berenstain oh no no no no no
Ravens Colts Ravens called the Battle of
Baltimore we get to see Andrew Luck yeah
Lamar Jackson yep and our guy
for Sims he sat homeys vendrick would
say yeah koe man says holla holla holla
see you guys later
be well talk soon